every song in the sense is at a triumph
of oversimplification every word is
perhaps we use words all the time
I learned from my father he says beware
the lingo centric predicament
you know the ethnocentric predicament
the anthropologist tries to understand
another culture but face it you're
always looking at through your own
colored glasses and you can't understand
it a hundred percent try as you might
similarly all of us who use words often
forget that other people hear that those
words and have different meanings so the
world is full of people throwing angry
words at each other the words don't hit
the bull's eye it often don't hit the
target at all they fly off into space
until two angry people says there's only
one thing those people understand and
what are our big jobs in the next
century at least is to find ways to
communicate words are better than
bullets
but when words fail try music try
pictures I used to say every time I see
somebody with a camera I say keep in
mind that they hope the pen would be
mightier than the sword it wasn't
perhaps the lens could be we can leap
the language barrier and this other arts
dancing food greatest of all we have
festivals up and down the Hudson River
shad fish festival in May of strawberry
shortcake Festival in June corn festival
in August Pumpkin Festival in October
and people who might highly disapprove
of my politics so come down they see
this beautiful beautiful sailboat the
man once said 'we've Seeger don't think
I agree with you not one tenth of one
percent but that sure is a beautiful
boat I call it a symphony of curves it's
a replica of the cargo boats that
carried bricks and lumber on the Hudson
150 years ago and we take 10,000 school
kids out every year
I confess though I'm very much a reader
holic I started reading early about
reading every book by a man named Ernest
Thompson Seton and nature writer and
when people asked I said tell people I'm
a communist they say what kind I said
well at age seven I read about the
American Indians no rich no poor and
anthropologists call that tribal
communism in that sense all our
ancestors were communists for hundreds
of thousands of years you realize I
think I'd still liked like it if I I'd
love to see a world without this huge
disparity of wealth it's getting bigger
and bigger every year you know can't go
on forever what to do about it some
people say well can't make an omelet
without breaking eggs is gonna have to
be something broken on the other hand
maybe there could be a lot of little
changes I'm right now very much in the
favor of small organizations I like
small business I worked with small
business people in my hometown my home
county of Dutchess County New York State
I'm really a big fan of small
organizations small churches small
scientific groups from all political
groups and if the reason is that
power-hungry people just seem to
gravitate towards big organizations
whether it's government or corporations
or big anything they're also big
organizations can be corrupted by by
people who want to do doing dirt
well his for instance I remember way
back in the round 1950 The Daily Worker
which I used to read regularly then
announced that somebody had been exposed
as an FBI spy been expelled from the
Communist
party 40 full years later the Manas it
starts it's a lolly they said oh no we
have your handwriting he said that's not
my handwriting
oh no we took it to a handwriting expert
forty years later it comes out it was a
real FBI spy they got the guy framed and
they had a probably his own andr and
writing expert to testify anyway oh
here's another example daniels singer
reported this in the nation a few years
ago i think also in the early 50s to
polish american communists decide to go
back to poland and help build socialism
there just at the time that a leading
poll decided he was gonna defect to the
USA he got in touch with the CIA all
they said very good we'll help you find
a job but there's a job you can do for
us before you leave Poland he says what
is it he says tell Stalin that these two
polish Americans are spies when they
were executed well
with all the bad things going on it's
very easy to get very very pessimistic
my grandson has a sign on his guitar
case there's no hope but I may be wrong
and when people say there is how could
you say this hope population needs to be
stabilized it's not getting stabilized
except in a few places and money's being
spent I go around with statistics to
show people you can't see this I guess
unless you come close but the bottom
line is what USA spends on armaments on
defense it's big line runs four inches
across the page Japan Germany France
England and so on
about one-fifth the length of that each
one of them and this is what in the
world needs education all sorts of
things it needs and the reason I took
the title of a it's laughter against
disaster is it I was about ten I
remember somewhat our skimming through a
newspaper I guess seeing HDL says the
human race is in a it's a race between
education and disaster but that sounds
so formal and real education is full of
happiness right when somebody learned
something they didn't know before a
great ray of light comes through you
feel like laughing I'm sure Archimedes
was laughing when he jumped out of the
bathtub having discovered the law of
specific gravity and ran down the street
hollering Eureka I've found it I'm sure
he was laughing that's what I'm thinking
when I say the race between a laughter
and disaster I subscribed to dozens of
little newsletters and I confess I could
spend more time reading then than
newspapers some of them are pacifist
publications some of them are music
publications some scientific
publications some medium big like
science magazine but uh and I skim
through the Sunday Times have for 70
years I guess
and I'd say newspapers are better than
they used to be
why television is so bad and I see
little things happening well a few big
things happening
I tell people who say there's no hope
did you expect to Nixon would leave
office the way he did and even though
there's not did you expect the Berlin
Wall to come down so peacefully no I
guess not
did you expect Mandela to be head of
South Africa no hope didn't guess that
well if you couldn't predict that don't
be so confident you can predict there's
no hope there are reserves of genius all
through this world and they'll show up
in all sorts of places oh I think I can
quote from memory but I brought his
quote with me Oren Lyons is the elected
leader of the Onondaga longhouse near
Syracuse New York he came to speak at
our Clearwater Annual Meeting
two years ago two and a half years ago
he's in much demand as a speaker very
good speaker although he teaches in
Buffalo and he also manages a lacrosse
team he was a lacrosse player when he
was young
but he'll go to the United Nations for
example and say who is here to represent
the Inuit of Canada or the Chukchi of
Siberia all the Tahitians and
Micronesians of the Pacific I am here to
speak for them and all the original
people you are destroying this world
with your money and your finance and
your so-called progress
well Lyons told us he said I found
myself in a world economic conference in
Switzerland and I was beaten two men who
were the leaders the CEOs of
billion-dollar corporations and I said
to them do you realize the way you're
using up the world's resources in a
sense you're headed for a brick wall do
you realize that and they said to me of
course mr. Lyons
we realize that but you must realize
that we have been put into our jobs
in order to make as much money as we can
for our stockholders if we don't do that
we're out of a job
lions and said are any of you
grandfathers number them said oh oh yes
when do you stop being a CEO and start
being a grandfather and they were silent
I don't know what exactly the right
thing to do well I noticed my wife and I
are more active now at this age than
ever I'm not only active we're not only
active up River but down in the city I
guess you know more than half the people
in the world live in cities now and if
there's going to be a world here in a
hundred years the city's gonna have to
be made livable who is going to do the
job the suburban Knights who fled the
city the cities are going to make decent
places because the city people decide
they're going to have to be made decent
places so I'm now busy in New York City
like I never expected I'd be helping it
in Bronx on the edge of the Harlem River
putting on an August festival we call it
our slogan is eight eight ninety eight
eight to August we hope to have a batch
of people there with boats and music and
food and games face painting who knows
and get a gang of people saying Bronx is
gonna be made a different place hope to
have the green gorillas there we have a
bet try to pop them at four hundred
gardens so far in New York City some
hardly bigger than that table but some
one acre across they come and go with
the people but some of them have stayed
there they've learned learn a phrase
that I found started with the corporate
world founders disease every small
organization should be aware that you
have at least two and I'd say three jobs
to do one is to do the main job the
others to see somebody else's go knows
how to do the job when you can no longer
do it right and the third is to do a
little bit of thinking about how to do
the job better I tell my socialist
friends how is it that not a single post
office department in the entire world
world thought of Federal Express now
post office departments you know were
among the first socialist organizations
well they saw this earlier
I'm sure you could say that a library is
a socialist organization museum a bridge
a ferry some would say national armies
instead of having every little Baron
wear his own mad army but post offices
were come to think Ben Franklin who was
Postmaster General of the colony wrote
with his daughter on horseback not too
far from my house laying out the Albany
Post Road around the 1760s and he was
the one who started other little
socialist organizations like volunteer
fire departments but there's a great
danger that you start an organization
seco the government will pay for it ha
ha ha it should have been the post
offices of the world that thought of
Federal Express in said it was one
ambitious guy he was a fighter pilot in
Vietnam came back and went to school
college on the GI Bill and dreamed up
the entire thing his professors turned
him down he didn't get his master's
thesis but his father was a businessman
and helped him get capital and of course
he's now one of the biggest corporations
in the country but he dreamed up the
whole thing not a single post office
department did have to confess that's
socialism as it was practiced anywhere
in the world didn't work out too well
nevertheless a lot of small
organizations whether you have you want
to call them private enterprise are in a
sense socialist my favorite little
magazine of all I have to give a plug
for it's called Rachel's environmental
and health weekly published in Annapolis
by dr. Peter Montague and a small gang
of hard-working people underpaid I'm
sure
only one page once a week and I read it
religiously gives some little story each
week that's where I heard about Gordon
Dern ill anybody know Gordon der Nova
chants or read of any Ria's box you
written a couple they had one of these
issues as a conservative speaks and he
journal was appointed by Bush to be head
of the Great Lakes Joint Commission and
there he made a good decision he says
let's make our decisions by consensus if
we can't agree neither Canada no USA is
gonna pay any attention to us I don't
want to waste my time well you can bet
the meetings were longer but four years
later he comes out with a book the
making of a conservative an
environmentalist he's still a
conservative Republican wants prayer in
school he's very much against abortion
he thinks Clinton should be jailed for
the rest of his life at least but
he also comes up with the suggestions
like this he says we know chlorinated
hydrocarbons are killing the environment
by killing us let's ban chlorine if I
have a thousand one one little
regulations well this was a suggestion
made by Barry commoner thirty years ago
nobody paid any attention to Barry
commoner I hope the country will listen
to Gordon Journal I'm trying to get him
a speaking engagements in the Hudson
Valley
he says Clark its chlorine is a
billion-dollar industry
we can't ban it overnight but we can
start this year with one step and next
year with another step in fifty years
from now there can be no more chlorine
in the world and we won't have to worry
like we do now about dioxin and a whole
batch of other things I've talked long
enough now so I I'll field whatever you
throw at me I'll put on my glasses so I
can read your questions well why don't
you
if I had a hat oh I'm sorry I beg your
pardon awesome this is secret do you
have a sense of accomplishment after
these many years of working to improve
our planet and the lives of people I
mean do you feel a sense of
accomplishment not as much as I'd like
but it gives me great pride to see not
dozens not hundreds but thousands and
who knows tens of thousands of people
around the world realizing that songs
can do things that is difficult for
speeches to do or pamphlets or even
articles in newspapers and granted 999
out of a thousand songs will be heard
briefly usually sung by the person who
made him up but some will go on and like
this land is your land was never
promoted it was never on the top 40 but
it did get in the school song books and
just went from one kid to another in one
person to another to that the whole
country knows it very well now and solo
I am proud that there's a whole batch of
people it doesn't matter what you call
him folk singing doesn't really make
much sense in the moderns there's as
many kinds of folk songs as there are
folks must be thousands different kinds
of folk music
Chinese folk music Jewish folk music
Caribbean folk music where have all the
progressives gone do they become
moderates and get elected to office
perhaps some some get involved in their
hometowns
some were in business some are in unions
some are even in government on one level
or another maybe these could try for me
to say of the many mistakes have made in
anybody my age has made a lot of
mistakes one of the mistakes I made was
not trying to support Adlai Stevenson in
1956 when I read that fantastic
statement that was found among his
papers after he died of a heart attack
in London he was a US Representative to
the United Nations and he made that
wonderful short statement gosh can
memorize it I should have memorized it
was denied we are on a tiny spaceship
dependent on its vulnerable air water
and soil and to its security and peace
the very eloquent statement he could
have carried on the tradition of
Franklin Roosevelt and gone beyond it
and I'm sorry that I didn't support him
in 1956 admittedly he was supported by
Daley of Chicago and a whole bunch of
Dixiecrat Democrats in Mississippi
otherwise I suppose you wouldn't have
gotten elected and I guess maybe that's
what politics teaches everybody to get
something done you got to work with a
lot of people that you really disagree
with very basically but that's what
happens when the flood comes along to it
to a town everybody's help they're
tossing sandbags you're not asking what
who they are as long as they can toss a
sandbag on and right now we do have a a
world crisis that everybody has to face
up to there will be no human race in a
few hundred years we don't have another
two thousand years to learn the Sermon
on the Mount
during the civil rights movement people
sang together and during the anti-war
movement people sang together is that
missing today to a certain extent
because she knows the African people
have such strong music traditions that
slavery couldn't stop it and nothing has
stopped Irish people have very strong
music traditions I decided there's
dominant cultural genes you say among
Italians cooking must be one of the
great things anyway and why is it that
that on one side of the English Channel
they're famous for food on the other
side of English Channel they're not but
but go on to the extraction do you have
any advice to Congress and the president
as they consider waging war against Iraq
wage war but not with weapons we can
vote I don't like to use the word war
because he got some military kaneki
connotations for the Sinai I had on my
study that Prince Adel life is a
struggle but not a warfare no Martin
Luther King taught us all and Gandhi did
what extraordinary things can be done
when the people of the world decide that
something needs to be done and a few
people might get killed but I wish I
could live long enough to see not only
nuclear weapons be something that he
talked about read about in history books
but biological weapons chemical weapons
no I think there's a worldwide truth if
that if there's a human race here in 200
years we'll also know that it's better
to talk than shoot but bombs always kill
innocent people always Baker small in a
Tokyo subway in Oklahoma City on
Hiroshima or in the villages of Iraq
you do believe the internet will bring
people together as you have attempted to
do in your life you bet
well the trouble is a lot of people in
the world have no access to it I went to
India in November with my grandson and
my wife we had a wonderful three-week
tour and among other places we visited
the state of Kerala as anybody here read
about the state of Kerala raise your
hand if you have one person two three
four bill mckibben wrote a nice little
book hope human and wild in one of the
three chapters without Carroll at 28
million people that's a small State for
India with its 950 million population
but Kerala population of California and
about 1/3 the actual acreage is on the
south west so the southern part of India
on the western side oh it's got a lot of
Christians there way back almost two
thousand years ago Saint Thomas came and
in the 14th century Catholic
missionaries came and found a whole
batch of Christians already there so 20%
of Kerala is Christian 22% Muslim 58%
Hindu but they all seem to live together
fairly peacefully they had a leftie
government for 10 or 20 years in Kerala
became 100 percent literate now this was
done by other socialist countries
Nicaragua and Cuba and so on but Kerala
I don't know what kind of a leftie
government I had all I know is there's
about 13 communist parties in India and
I don't know what other socialist
parties anyway they poured money into
education now they're 100 percent
literate well the standard is read 30
words a minute right seven words a
minute if you can do that to illiterate
and we met a woman up in New Delhi
inspired by carolers example who started
India's own version of it each one teach
one campaign she's made I suppose it's a
manila envelope with some pieces of
paper inside and she gives it to a
teenager 14 or 15 year old baby says you
our project this year is to teach find
somebody who cannot read or write their
own name and you teach them at the end
of the year you will get a prize if they
can do that and she said with smile of
course you know who really learns it's
the kid this middle class kid learns
what it's like to be at the bottom of
the ladder so I think that I'd like to
see project I've got a friend from
Kerala who works for IBM and we've we've
we got a little project we're working
with a teenager in New Delhi to see if
we can find ways to get used computers
which as you know are fairly cheap given
to villages in the third world that can
show they are 100% literate the whole
village can read or write then they'll
get a computer and it's not as simple as
that you also have to arrange keep keep
it in repair what do you think of the
press and Monica and the Monica Lewinsky
case
I I'm afraid I don't look at it enough
to but have an opinion
I really don't in the 1950s you were
blacklisted in the 1960s you were
censored at CBS
now you've been honored by the Kennedy
Center and you spoke at the National
Press Club what is it like to have
traveled such a path and could you
comment on your treatment by the press
over the years well all my life I've
said I believe in the censorship but I
think everybody's got to be their own
censor I'd like to see six billion
sensors every time I sing anywhere I
speak I'm thinking of what should I say
what should I not say I'm not interested
in shocking people the reason I made up
that last song was very specifically I
want to get people laughing about the
different definitions of words and
hopefully during the next century people
all around the world will be laughing at
their different different definitions of
words my friend Josh white jr. made up a
nice rap he calls English is crazy and I
do it everywhere I go especially for
young people or for that matter people
who are trying to study English what a
language two million words which is
there any other language when you're hot
house burned down when it burns up you
fill out a form when you fill it in so
huh I don't know if that answers your
question
as an inductee into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame do you think Rock has had a
harmful or beneficial impact on American
music well it's hard to sing a quiet
song when there's a very loud woman
being sung nearby I look upon rock is
just one more example of African
traditions being enthusiastically
adopted by different peoples around the
world when they hear them you know
everything from since the beginning of
the 20th century people who did not
approve of African rhythms were writing
this is destroying our children this
ragtime this is destroying our children
this jazz this is destroying our
children this rocket that matter of fact
that was one of the musing think when
you enter the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
in Cleveland it's in the large letters
this music is destroying our children
who do you like to listen to the funny
thing is I hardly ever in my life have
listened to recordings I did briefly
when I was working at the Library of
Congress that was my job and I was
fascinated to hear thousands of songs
scratchy 78rpm aluminum discs recorded
in the Appalachians and in the prairies
and so on but except for that I
practically never listened to a loud
speaker if I can help it my older
brother loved radio and I took him
camping and I was outraged that he'd
brought a radio in hey you listen to the
birds and the wind and the trees he was
listening to his radio well he later on
became a prominent radar astronomer
here's a question from someone in our
audience here my daughter was just
admitted to Harvard and is also a
musician of considerable accomplishment
which tract would you advise
I always advise young people while
you're young try lots of different
tracks and lots of them will be dead end
you'll backtrack but how do you know
unless you try
be careful but uh I do I've averaged
young people to travel when they're
young when you get older he gets a lot
more expensive admittedly it's not safe
especially for women bridge go with a
friend but uh I and I realized I didn't
completely answer that previous question
censorship I'm the I'm a Luxembourgian
communist you know Rosa Luxemburg wrote
a letter to Lenin in 1919 just before
she was assassinated by some German
fascist fascists comrade Lenin I read
that you of instituted press censorship
and restricted the right of freedom to
assembly assemble don't you realize that
in a few years all the decisions in your
country are going to be made by a few
elite and the masses will only be called
into dutifully applaud your decisions
why wasn't she prophetic
the time in the world is turned on
Cuba's Fidel Castro what's your view of
this last communist boss Castro is a
very interesting boss one of the most
interesting in the entire history of the
world in many ways he doesn't make
decisions he delegates much more and he
in the friend he was younger he would
hop into a helicopter and and fly
unannounced to a factory somewhere that
was in trouble you know all of a sudden
the factory just came to a stop
everybody was standing around he'd stand
up in the helicopter say what's going
wrong here and rank-and-file people
would speak out and an hour later they'd
set up some subcommittee somewhere to
try and straighten out what was going
wrong extraordinary a way of governing
but I am worried is everybody who's
concerned for the future of Cuba's
what's gonna happen when this
extraordinary man is no longer around
and Cuba and every country in the world
needs to be worried about founders
disease every organization in the world
but I'm supporting all the people trying
to send medical assistance to Cuba that
he used to it's only a matter of time
before there'll be more and more people
going down there I've been there three
times
I have friends who've lived there many
decades loved the place so I know this
it's perfectly true what was a hundred
thousand people are more left marielle a
few years ago and went 90 miles to get
to the USA I bet if it had been if
Venezuela had been 90 miles from USA or
Colombia or a whole batch of other
player it made a lot more than 100
thousand the astonishing it was only a
hundred thousand my friend in Cuba said
you know in the months after that the
local crime went way down could you
suggest some new song themes for the
Millennium Irving Berlin was once asked
what's a good subject he said peace but
it's a hard thing to write about you
don't want to say we want peace we want
peace find a way by indirection as good
poetry so often does surprise people and
my guess peace might be on many many
different levels family peace school
peace industrial peace scientific my
father used to say that scientists had
the most dangerous religious belief in
the world scientists who say what do you
mean we make our decisions by careful
observation double-checked and
triple-checked and then try and draw
logical conclusions oh no said my father
you decided that an infinite increase in
empirical information was a good thing
can you prove it
the Hudson River is one of America's
greatest natural treasures and you have
worked very hard for its restoration
what should we do to protect the
remainder of the nation's estuaries get
lots of local groups out there pushing
and they'll find the things to do don't
leave it up to government don't leave it
up to the newspapers or the magazines
get busy wherever you are in your
neighborhood and you can have fun at the
same time doing it here's that for
instance I told you about New York City
one of the new organizations is called
floating the Apple archaeologists quit
digging in the near East says I gotta go
back and help save New York
he loved to roll in man in his 50s who
just loves to wrote boats and he found
the world's most beautiful row boat up
in Mystic Connecticut it was a replica
reproduction of a boat that had been
given to Lafayette in the year 1874 in
those days on fight hall Street we used
to have big row boats and when a new
ship was in the morning they'd see a new
ships anchored in the harbor they'd race
out the first one to get there got the
best jobs the pilot the mail whatever so
they were very fast sleek row boats and
this particular one had won many races
was called the American star and when
they took Lafayette on a row he probably
sent these what a magnificent pulling
boat
they said general we give it to you it's
yours after World War two it was found
sitting in a chateau outside Paris in
perfect condition for 200 years 150
years it had been sitting there and
Mystic Connecticut the marine museum
took the lines off it as I said measured
it to the millimeter and built one just
like it
and this archeologist says can I make
more sure and down in New York he's
making one after the other with
young people learning how to solve and
how to measure and how to sandpaper and
so on and when they're made they got out
and roll and what fun it is and they
have rowing races with their friends and
so on to date two years ago they had
three one year ago they had five
now they got 13 I'm predicting a few
more decades are going to have 50 or
hundred of them they'll be all around
New York and the young people of New
York City will at last realize that they
don't leave
need to leave their rivers up to
Commerce they can enjoy them it's in
fact just last two weeks ago I visited a
group in Williamsburg North Brooklyn El
Puente is the name of the place a Puerto
Rican activist found an old Catholic
Church was going to be torn down he says
don't tear it down they made it into a
an academy of peace and justice 150
young people they're learning the 3 R's
but also learning singing dancing and
mural painting and they're changing the
face of Williamsburg and they Fernandez
who was for a while the Commissioner of
Education got him accredited they're
part of the Board of Education now and
they got a big new building and they're
all eager buildable
to who knows what's gonna happen in New
York well before I ask the last question
I'd like to thank you very much for
coming today now we have a certificate
of appreciation to you for coming a
National Press Club coffee mug so you
can drink some nice Hudson River water
out of that perhaps and since you are an
historical figure a history of the
National Press Club which in our 90th
anniversary year the National Press Club
which in our 90th anniversary a year for
question today have you ever been to the
top of old what's it like up there
if anybody has seen the southern
Appalachians you know how they missed
hangs in the black valley it if they do
look beautiful
I've been there matter of fact where I
live is just the northern Appalachians
and we have spoken the valley
occasionally sometimes our houses in the
middle of the mist we can't see the
river sometimes we're above the mist and
when you see mist all over the river